hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in
on you
checking in to see how your week's going
you know no self-promotion
just a nice friendly how are you
saratoga springs this saturday
um
with tony v just calling to see you know
see how your week's going you know it's
thursday it's a very exciting day you
get your paycheck
you know you lie to yourself that you're
not going out tonight you know you're
going to save your money this week and
what happens
oh come on i can be hungover for friday
i'll be all right oh look at you
thank you brought me a little cup of
[ __ ] joe here
um
the lovely mia
and then what ends up happening right
you go out thursday you spend 40 percent
of your check
then you're like god i gotta [ __ ]
shut it down here this isn't gonna be
one of these things where i blow my
whole paycheck and i'm [ __ ]
brown-bagging it on monday for lunch all
right at some point i gotta [ __ ] show
a little responsibility
stop [ __ ] boozing
and and and you know
save a little something this week but
then what happens somebody calls you
friday like all right i'll go out
i'm just gonna have a couple i'm gonna
be home by 10 o'clock
i'm going to wake up i'm going to the
gym
you know i'm going to take my
plyometrics
geometric [ __ ] class whatever the
[ __ ] kids do now with the trx tix
[ __ ] bands right
doing all of this [ __ ] like you're gonna
go work for cirque du soleil
and uh
you know go take a [ __ ]
what are those classes that the you know
people just [ __ ] with the kettlebells
they take up all the space and there's
no place to stretch anymore because it's
the uh crossfit section i've been going
to a local gym here great [ __ ] gym
all right definitely a great gym um
i like the guy that's [ __ ] on his
phone at the gym
you know what i mean just like texting
and he's sitting at a [ __ ] station
that you wanted you know maybe like the
lat pull downs or the squat thing and
you just want to [ __ ] use it and he's
literally taking like seven minute
breaks between because he doesn't
realize that he's just like disappearing
into his [ __ ] phone
um
whenever i see people doing that they're
never in good shape
you know what i mean but those lunatics
that walk around with the jug of water
and that little [ __ ] notebook writing
down every rep and how much weight they
use those people are always shredded
so i'm asking you today
who are you or as they say up here in
massachusetts who are you
are you that [ __ ] idiot you know
that's just listening to his music and
taking seven minutes between [ __ ]
reps staring at your phone staring at
your phone
you know you want to be water jug guy
looking like you're ready to reboot the
[ __ ] a-team
hmm
oh that's pretty good
it's a pretty good espresso god damn it
my new this is my [ __ ] right now bill
nobody asked you what your [ __ ] was well
i don't care
all right in my head you did
in my head you asked me
you know bill enough of this [ __ ]
talking about the gym what is your [ __ ]
oh last thing i'm gonna say about the
gym
is uh they got this shredded dude that
does the [ __ ] uh
i just said what it was the cross
crossfit the crossfit how old were son
he does he
he hosts
he runs
he he he manages a crossfit class
whatever the [ __ ] teaches there's the
word he teaches a crossfit class
and uh
you know which i would love to take but
i've never seen one exercise that
wouldn't [ __ ] my body up
all right we're just going to jump up
and down here to get warmer i can't do
that can't do that
we're gonna pick up a kettlebell we're
gonna hold it up over our head and then
we're gonna slowly go down and sit on
our ass and then get back up again while
always holding the kettlebell up why
would you do that
what do you think what'd you wake up
thinking today you know my rotator cuffs
feel pretty good
you know what i like about my back it's
aligned
i think i'll take a [ __ ] stone with a
handle on it and lift it above my
[ __ ] head and then try to sit down on
my ass like
i couldn't believe they could do it but
there was a well killed me one of the
one of the days i went over there
oh jesus listen to this [ __ ] i [ __ ]
go over there there's a bunch of uh
like old white women in the class
right like oh but meaning my age
okay
the kids are in their 20s they're going
to [ __ ] college and they're out there
doing this [ __ ] crossfit [ __ ] and
what was hilarious
was
the the crossfit teacher was playing dmx
so
it's a bunch of older white ladies like
my age and he's [ __ ] playing y'all
gonna make me lose my mind up in here up
in here his curse words and [ __ ] i'm
just sitting there going like just
[ __ ] laughing about how like how much
it's changed
you know i know i swear my brains out so
i'm not like offended or anything but
like you couldn't [ __ ] do like
couldn't just be playing
songs that had like the f word and all
of that stuff my favorite one is every
once in a while like you know niece or
nephew
will have um
a birthday
and you know they're all sneaker heads
or whatever so i can't just go to
athlete's foot or one of those [ __ ]
places i have to go to the sneakerhead
store
and you go in there and every time i've
gone in there it's just like
um
you know it sounds like i'm doing
stand-up there's so many f-bombs and
they're dropping the n-word and all of
that it's [ __ ] hilarious is all of
that shit's going on you're just like
yeah do you have this in a size seven
and nobody notices
they're just like shazam in the song
like oh i like this
you know my kid's gonna be selling
lemonade on the side of the street later
on
raising money for uganda
i don't know why i picked that country
but we're going to say uganda and i'm
this would be a good song to play
i don't really listen to the lyrics as
much as
i listen to the energy does that make
sense
because i feel like we're all just like
energy right and it's all about the
energy that you're putting out because
you put out the energy
isn't if you put out positive energy
aren't you going to attract negative
[ __ ]
isn't that how the universe like the
opposites attract
you know
i think that's true
i think if you're too positive you
really attract horrible people into your
life why is that built because i see a
lot of sweet hats
out there with absolute dicks and i'm
not talking about coming-of-age movies
from the 1980s
all right
i'm talking about my wife putting up
with me
my wife is a sweetheart
you do have to remind yourself
if you like me every once in a while
just you know
hey bill you just got you check in with
yourself like hey bill you know what be
a great thing for you to do today
not be you
what if you became a different you
this [ __ ]
coffee's outstanding
mm-hmm
i don't know where the [ __ ] they got
that but they knew what they were doing
um
oh speaking of that
one of my buddies sent me this ac dc
video and then playing bad boy boogie
with bon scott and i don't know it's a
tv show whatever but it looked like this
little club
and um
i of course clicked on the video and i
watched the whole video my son came over
and he was like freaking out jumping up
and down he loves music right
and um
it's hilarious my mother-in-law goes
she heard the music she goes
who's that who you listen to i said oh
it's uh it's acdc she goes
well they know what to do with those
guitars
i was thinking like that would have been
the perfect intro for like a [ __ ]
video back in the day when they used to
make music videos
you know they used to always have an old
person
and they were either completely against
what the band was doing because they
thought it was noise or
they were into it or they hated it in
the beginning and by the end they were
[ __ ] into it i can't think of the
video but i just feel like that happened
a lot didn't milton berle at one point
didn't he like not like what rat was
playing and then by the end they were
all sort of dancing to it
um
[Music]
and milton berle was somehow
related to somebody in that band
isn't that right i can't remember
i do remember the rat behind the [ __ ]
music though
it wasn't just behind the music it was
behind the [ __ ] music because it was
rat
and uh
jesus christ
the [ __ ] this i love that band right
but the [ __ ] dysfunction in that band
is just unbelievable i feel like
everybody in that band at some point has
tried to go out
and you know
bobby blotzer's rat
so and so is rat right
uh
it was d martini that was their their
lead guitar stephen percy was this lead
singer
i like that guy that guy's a pro [ __ ]
still in shape still can sing
um
didn't let himself go to
[ __ ] you know when you get to be my age
and you go out you see the [ __ ] bands
you know
when you were a kid yeah it's always
good like if it's that that perfect
combination of they stayed in shape but
they look their age and then you're like
all right
like i feel like that dude from rat
looks like a still looks like a badass
right so anyway one time i was watching
the uh not the behind the music on rat
the behind the [ __ ] music on rat
and i don't know what happened but we
were talking about this last night i did
a couple of shows up at uh giggles
um
let me not talk about that let me finish
this story and and uh i was hanging with
this comedian robbie prince who i hadn't
seen for [ __ ] ever right
hilarious comic
and we were somehow talking about rat
oh i know
cause paul d'angelo another comedian up
there
uh who's hanging i [ __ ]
lived in the same building he lived in
in l.a like jesus christ 27 [ __ ]
years ago twenty five six seven years
ago right
and i was saying that [ __ ] place i
never got my deposit back did you get
your deposit and blah blah all that [ __ ]
and i was like um
i told the story how the people that
were
running the place
stole from me
that's how we got started talking about
rat because i was on the road for two
weeks and they needed to check the smoke
detectors so they had a reason to go
into my apartment and when they went in
there you know you can just tell the
toilet water's all the way down
you realize someone isn't there
and they [ __ ] robbed me right
so i come home
from the road and i see a you know
a notice
on my um
on my door saying that they were going
to check them so i went in and it was
just that you know
that feeling i could just feel like
something was wrong
i sat down and there was just something
[ __ ] wrong
and i got up and i started looking
around and i realized i was missing a
camera
and someone had
stolen some cds
and they were a rap fan right
and uh they took my biggie and uh
whatever the [ __ ] else i was hello cool
j whatever i was listening to back then
wu-tang
um when that second one came out
uh and not not the 36 chambers the
second one that came out
in the late 90s and it was also the the
uh
it was it was the biggie one where he
was literally leaning up against the
hearse that one was like 1997 i'm going
going back back to cali all of that [ __ ]
and um so i [ __ ] went down to the
manager the next day and i said yes you
know
whoever came in and checked my smoke
detectors if it was one or two people
they've robbed my apartment because
it's locked from the inside there's no
evidence of anybody breaking in and i
have this notice
can i speak to them and then the
managers will be like i don't appreciate
you coming down here accusing people
and i mean i'm like you [ __ ] idiot
that means you did it
and i was like no i want to talk to him
he goes i have the power i have the
power that's what he was saying
it's like that saturday morning cartoon
i have the power whatever the [ __ ] it
was and i was like oh really
you have the power oh okay buddy
so i sit outside the office and as
people are coming in
to potentially live there i go hey just
to let you know people connected with
this stole from my apartment and this
guy's not helping me at all and they
would just turn around and walk away and
the [ __ ] guy was
you know eyeballing me and i'm looking
at him i go i can do this all [ __ ]
day
all day just like that dad i got into
the fight with i could run laps around
you i could run laps i was totally
bluffing because i was going on the road
for another few weeks
like the next two weeks and the woman i
was dating at the time goes you should
go and [ __ ] up his car
and i'm like no i shouldn't i should
either fight this guy or just [ __ ]
leave it alone
so what did i do i [ __ ] left it alone
so anyway i was telling that story
um
it's always better to [ __ ] leave it
alone i think you just leave it
especially if you're going somewhere in
life you just [ __ ] leave it alone
who gives a [ __ ] and they're gonna
slowly swirl down the drain
and you know
you're gonna be you'll be gonna be fine
who gives a [ __ ] you know
but every once in a while
i don't know
depends on how much money you have in
your bank account you know i guess you
could go fight somebody but it's just
like
it's [ __ ] sue happy once you get any
money you got a thousand bucks in the
bank you can't get into a fight anymore
because then you get in a fight and one
of two things is going to happen you're
either going to lose
right
or you're going to win and get sued
you're losing either way either way
you're losing and then i always look at
like you know
it wasn't so much back then but like
nowadays like these [ __ ] kids man
they don't that that martial arts mixed
martial arts [ __ ] is like mainstream
god forbid you get some [ __ ] lunatic
who knows how to choke you out
[ __ ] starts choking out there's no
ref to be like all right all right he
tapped he tapped and the guy can [ __ ]
hold it too long it's just it's just not
[ __ ] worth it
it's a couple of cds oh i'll go buy some
more right
um
you know but the main thing was i didn't
feel like it might you know have this
guy break into my apartment and then
also [ __ ] you know beat the [ __ ] out
of me you know what if i lost that too
then i'm going upstairs and [ __ ]
bleeding and then i don't have any
[ __ ]
wu tang to listen to
you know or i could just say f
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right i know what
i'll do i'll just change the locks
so i changed the locks on them and then
when i moved out i just made sure i
locked it up
i think that was my big [ __ ] you to them
i changed the deadbolt so they had to
call a locksmith that probably took them
all of 20 minutes to get into the
apartment and meanwhile they kept my 700
deposit you know what i'm going to
change this [ __ ] story because it's
making me upset again so anyway i told
that story last night
and um
robbie thought i said
i was a rat fan
not rap so he started talking about rat
and then we started talking about the
rat behind the [ __ ] music not the
behind the music rat you got to watch sp
rat behind the [ __ ] music
and there's this part in it
that they put together where everyone in
the band was making fun of the bass
player
just making fun of his stage moves and
all of that [ __ ] i felt so bad for the
bass player
because it was clear that
it looked like they all randomly
in their interview at some point hey
talk about all the band members when
they came around to the bass player they
just were making fun of him
they're making fun of all of his stage
moves
and they go you know he had the uh
he had the helicopter move and then they
show him and there's this really bad 80s
move
and the worst one was the uh uh where
the where am i where he would pretend
like he was [ __ ] up like jim morrison
but he was totally stoned sober and they
would cut to him doing it and then and
they named like five different moves and
they all the band members individually
their individual interviews were just
making fun of the [ __ ] bass player
and then they cut to the bass player he
hasn't i guess has no idea that that's
what they're doing and that's how
they're going to edit it together and
he's all going like you know i believed
when you know when you go up there uh
you put on a show and we cut to him and
spandex doing his helicopter move as all
the other guys were like rolling out
their eyes like i thought the worst one
was the where am i
because he would pretend like he was
[ __ ] up but he wasn't he was stone
sober and just i can't imagine being the
bass player knowing that all the other
guys hated you your [ __ ] stage moves
and all these years later they're
throwing you under the tour bus there
and just laughing at you
and uh i just can't imagine like
what a mind [ __ ] that must be
to like
be literally become a rock star
and you're still the [ __ ] nerd that
everybody's making fun of but like that
is i'll tell you though that is a great
one
um
that behind the music and then what you
do is you then go online and you read
about their next 20 years of that band
all
the [ __ ] dysfunction it's amazing
that they can never get back on stage
but somehow you know
somehow in the end money everybody
figures it out
and they're able to uh
i don't know get it back together but uh
old freckles speaking of that speaking
of 80s bands and all of that stuff and
the [ __ ] that i grew up with
um
i'm going to be doing a show up in san
francisco because i'm going to catch
that uh
the motley crue def leppard poison um
joan jett
show uh i gotta see that tour
you know
you know i mean one of all of them gonna
be
together again i wanna [ __ ] see that
i want to see how they held up
you know tommy lee is one of my favorite
[ __ ] drummers of all time
um joan jett is one of the biggest
badass
rockers of all [ __ ] time there's a
lot there that i want to see um
i did see def leppard at uh
where was it um
the whiskey a few months ago and they
were [ __ ] killing it so i'm looking
forward to seeing them give you a
[ __ ] great night you know and i've
been hearing nothing but good [ __ ] about
the tour and uh
you're playing baseball stadiums
why the [ __ ] not right um so i'm very
excited
to go up there fat oh and speaking of
that i got together with some uh with a
high school buddy of mine and some of
his friends
and uh
speaking of like just
uh [ __ ] music from back in the day
listen to this setlist
that we put together
this setlist should have been called
gold's gym 1989
and i cannot even begin to tell you how
much [ __ ] fun i had
i i jammed with the guys we played tnt
ac dc highway to hell ac dc
38 special hold on loosely
brian adams summer of 69
lover boy
working for the weekend
refugee tom petty and the heartbreaker
stan lynch one of my favorite drummers
of all time
kiss
tears of falling very tricky song
and then the last one i played
with them was uh dawkin breaking the
chains
breaking the chains
um
and i had a i just had a [ __ ] blast i
had not i had not played drums
you know since i've been out here
and um
it was just a you know just a great
group of guys and everybody just you
know having a good time and then also
[ __ ]
like talking about all those bands
in like
in a serious way joking around about you
know
how funny some of the [ __ ] lyrics are
and all of that [ __ ] but it was uh
it was just a [ __ ] great time and uh
my buddy high school buddy you know
had bought a a new motorcycle bought
like a [ __ ] uh
i guess timed out police motorcycle to
the second one that he's had he got rid
of the other one and um
just a ass bike it just i swear to god
man
i want to get like a [ __ ] heart
harley road king so bad i feel like
they're safe as far as like
they're safer than those you know
really fast ones because they're just
wide
and you can see him have like the
windscreen with like the three lights i
swear to god
um next time i do like montana or
wyoming or some [ __ ] like that i'm gonna
go i've already talked to dean and go
dean we're gonna go [ __ ]
go to a harley dealership we're gonna
rent them we're just gonna do a run
through the [ __ ] state
and uh loop back around you know rent
the bikes for like a week that
is a [ __ ]
great idea i think
um and i can do it up in the middle of
nowhere where i don't have to worry
about anything but there's always
something right then i'll be up there in
some [ __ ]
i don't know
moose or some [ __ ] will run out in front
of the bike
but i just think as an american
you know at some point in your life
you have to be out in the middle of
nowhere right in a harley i mean at some
point you have to experience that
considering um the amount of people that
have done that
and just never got off the bike and just
became a lifer like yeah this is what
i'm doing this is the greatest feeling
ever so i mean why the [ __ ] wouldn't you
want to experience that
so um
getting back uh
to uh
oh i never said what my um well you know
what my [ __ ] is this is what it is for
breakfast
uh i think i already told you guys this
i have a stubble espresso
and then
about like 20 minutes later i have an
orange and that's it
and it just [ __ ] levels me out for
the day i'm thinking rationally
about food as opposed to starting the
day with like
a salty breakfast
or you know something i never do like a
syrupy breakfast i [ __ ] i can't do
syrup anymore
i'm old people i'm [ __ ] old i do
syrup and it's literally like
like that's at my age if you have like a
waffle or a pancake you might as well
have just [ __ ] roofied yourself
okay you're gonna be [ __ ]
cruising until about 11 30 a.m and then
you're gonna do that first yawn and
you're gonna be face down at your
[ __ ] desk
so um anyway last night
i did two shows up at giggles i want to
thank mike clark
lenny clack tony v
trying to name everybody that was up
there
dan smith
paul d'angelo robbie prince todd parker
uh
i know i'm gonna forget something we
just
we just had a [ __ ] blast just [ __ ]
hanging out
steve bjork
um
paul gilligan
um
i know there was more people up there
anyway oh don
johnny peasy
and people are up there with their sons
and uh
all of that [ __ ] um
we were just [ __ ] hanging out i pull
up
everybody's sitting outside of giggles
you know tony v is holding court and
everybody's in a circle just [ __ ]
smoking cigars
the show mike clark's bringing out
pizzas and stuff
shrimp scampi all these [ __ ] new
england classics and then we're just
going in doing a set
coming back out just telling [ __ ]
stories and then we did the second show
and the first crowd was great second
crowd was like [ __ ] over the top
pretty hammered um
but uh i really want to thank mike clark
because i needed those shows
to uh you know for this [ __ ] weekend
here people all right i'm in the bubble
i'm in the [ __ ] bubble i'm doing
knicks
tomorrow night
and uh then i'm saratoga springs and
then i got the the mother of all gigs
i'm doing fenway park
and uh just those two shows last night
really boosted my confidence i can't
[ __ ] wait
to get up there and uh it's funny people
people keep saying like you know make
sure you make sure you enjoy it
when you're doing fenway make sure you
make sure you you know
you take it all in it's like you can't
do that and stand up you can't enjoy it
you can't take it all in you have to be
funny every [ __ ] six to eight seconds
i'm not out here [ __ ]
i was joking last night i'm not out here
sailing a boat
you know
just even that imagine you can't you
know what i mean
it's like if i start taking it in you
immediately start bombing it's like you
just start losing altitude
so um
[Music]
i am gonna [ __ ] take it in i'm gonna
be looking out at fenway park when i'm
there i still can't believe that i'm
gonna do it and uh this whole week
like i really started getting like
anxious about it and being like i just
wish it was [ __ ] tonight let's do it
and then after last night
um
hanging out with everybody and
telling the stories and doing a couple
of shows and watching other comics and
just hanging with all the guys
you know
just made me nice and [ __ ] chill and
i was telling mike i was like dude i
[ __ ] needed this so
i'm very excited um now for the weekend
and uh
i can enjoy the last little bit of my
vacation here
and whatnot and with that let me read a
little uh a little bit of advertising
here
um before i go downstairs and have my
orange
um
all right hey how about the yankees tell
me you guys didn't need that [ __ ] a
walk-off grand slam in the bottom of the
uh
10th to win it
um
god knows they needed that so
you know as much as i root against the
[ __ ] yankees i want to see him in the
playoffs
i actually do i mean that's that's good
for baseball do you know what i mean
when you have a team with the most
success all the [ __ ] money you want
them in there you need you need a
[ __ ] villain
um
it gives me a point to you know watch it
or i want to see somebody who hasn't
been in there for a while like i'm kind
of watching the uh you know the
cleveland guardians
you know and it's kind of crazy like
what if for some reason they just get
[ __ ] hot and they they
win their first world series in almost
80 years
74 years
i think it was 1948 the last time they
won
you know and then all of these these all
these hardcore
uh cleveland fans that don't want to
call them the guardians then what do
they do
they kind of got it then they have to
buy that would be really good
to bring all the old school people that
still want the [ __ ] chief wahoo and
the [ __ ] indians
you know what i mean if they win a
championship you're gonna have to get a
t-shirt that says
cleveland guardians
2022 world series champions you just
you'd have to you'd have to get it you
just would
so um
anyway uh oh i went by one of my
two nights in a row my two favorite bar
pizza places up here
um i got i got some [ __ ] pizzas they
were great i've still yet to have a
steak and cheese because i'm going to
the gym i'm doing a good job i didn't go
the last two days but
[ __ ] hanging in there but there's a
steak and cheese place i'm going to
today
and this is the one that me and my wife
love
and um
oh dude i went to the [ __ ] ocean
actually swam in the ocean still was
freaked out
but like i get it now i understand why
people go into the ocean i don't get
swimming out to a buoy and coming back
like you never watched the first scene
in jaws but i get it
anyways let me read the uh
advertising
uh helix everybody helix
how long have you had your mattress
how was your sleep improved the helix
lineup includes 14 unique mattresses i
got to get one of these [ __ ] things
i've had the same mattress
since obama
including a collection of luxury models
who was president the last time you
bought a [ __ ] mattress that's what
they should ask a mattress for big and
tall sleepers even a mattress made just
for kids
so how will you know which helix helix
mattress works best for you and your
body take the helix sleep quiz and find
your perfect mattress in under two
minutes and your personalized mattress
is shipped right to your door free of
charge helix knows there's no better way
to test out a new mattress than by sl uh
sleeping it
by sleeping on it in your own home
that's why they offer a hundred night
risk free trial try out your new helix
mattress see how your body adjusts and
if you decide it's not the best fit fit
you're welcome to return for all for a
full refund models with memory foam
layers to provide optimal pressure
relief if you sleep on your side
models with more i never know do you
want a [ __ ] hard mattress or a firm
you want support for your back right
i never understood how that works right
models with the more responsive foam to
cradle your body for essential support
in stomach and back sleeping positions
plus enhanced cooling features to keep
you from overheating at night
oh that's for the bankers
you know
knowing that they're [ __ ] stealing
from people uh if you don't love it i
know you will but if you don't they will
pick it up for you and give you a full
refund uh helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
burr with helix better sleep starts now
um oh hey if you want a great summertime
movie that i started watching
that i feel is like a really great like
throwback to all the action movies that
i grew up on
is the new uh uh ryan gosling billy bob
thornton uh
gray man it's just a [ __ ] it's a fun
goddamn movie
i got into like the first 20 minutes of
it there's a scene
uh a fight scene on an airplane
with all these special effects that's
pretty [ __ ] incredible
um
you know it's kind of the perfect thing
it's like a [ __ ] 80s action movie
with like some of the best actors out
there
so uh
i know it's enjoyable
except i don't like when they [ __ ]
you know kidnap kids i always hate that
[ __ ] storyline but i'm like
this really has hero vibes so i know the
kids can i hope the kid's gonna be all
right
anyway um
that is it that is the podcast please
enjoy the music interlude
uh
picked out by the great andrew themilis
and then afterwards we're gonna have a
bonus episode of the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast have a great weekend yet [ __ ]
um i can't wait for the monday morning
podcast
um
i usually do it sunday but i'm gonna
wait till after i do fenway
and i'll let you guys know how it goes
but uh from the bottom of my heart thank
you for everybody that has bought
tickets over the years and thank you to
everybody
that bought tickets to see me um
this weekend uh both in new york and in
massachusetts
i am now officially
really excited and looking forward to
sunday thank you to for the wonder
because of the wonderful stage time i
got from mike clark and everybody up at
giggles all right that is it
go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll talk to you
on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
uh jesus august
18th
yeah that's the month
and that's the date and it's the year
2014.
um how are you do you realize you when
you think about that it's 2014 if we
actually make it to the 2090 how people
are going to be looking back at us like
the way you know in the 1900s you look
back at 1914 everybody was walking
around really fast
do you think that'll happen with us no
bill they have hd tv
and with the rate of global warming all
right you [ __ ] kind we're all gonna
be underwater
um
you know what you know be funny uh bet
water world
do you think that movie will make a
bunch of [ __ ] money as the polar ice
caps start to melt
everybody would be like you know i think
we were wrong about this one we gave
this movie a lot of [ __ ] criticism
the guy was actually way ahead of his
time uh bill why are you talking about
kevin costner
because i actually have a movie coming
out with him believe it or not old fancy
pants freckle boy over here
i did a movie last summer in uh new
orleans some of you listen to this
podcast might remember
um
and uh it was hard as [ __ ] but it was a
it was a wonderful uh wonderful it was a
wonderful time and uh mike binder wrote
directed it octavius spencer kevin
costner
uh they're all in it it's a um
how would i describe the movie it's a
courtroom drama old school courtroom
drama
and what do you play bill i play kevin
costner's lawyer
enough boston accent in there um i'm
actually going to a film festival coming
up toronto
with the debut of that movie and uh
or whatever at a film festival i guess
and then it comes out in october
so there you go look at that i've barely
given you any laughs i've come right out
right out of the gate just whoring
myself out
i'm actually hoping to get mike binder
on the podcast uh as we get closer to
the date that's uh
he's actually one of the legendary
stand-ups from the comedy store
back in the day
and uh he told me a bunch of great
stories and all that stuff and um
[Music]
so he'll obviously be a great guest
speaking of which last night i went down
to the uh
well the first thing i did was i went
out and i [ __ ] jammed with the band
man
i'm doing another one of those uh
goddamn comedy jams tonight uh
and dressing up like the drummer that
i'm imitating again which of course is
uh
it's so it is ridiculous so i take off
any sort of pressure for any sort of
audience member
where you know is there anything worse
than having to go see your friends
banned
even if they're [ __ ] unless they're
really [ __ ] good then you're like oh
god maybe they're gonna make it i should
start picking up some wires maybe i
could be a roadie
dude you you you forgot where you came
from man you remember i used to go see
you down at friendlies in the ground
round
either way you [ __ ] right so i just
don't want anybody going down anybody
who's going out to this thing i don't
want anybody even remotely to think that
i'm taking this
other anywhere other than this is just a
fun as hell thing to do
um
i want to do some jokes about tommy lee
you know like i did with john bonham
it's fun it's just a good [ __ ] time
so
i'll tell you trying to find a tommy lee
uh
uh uh costume is it's [ __ ] difficult
the guys had like 90 different looks
and like most of them he's not wearing a
shirt and i'm just too [ __ ] pasty
that's like i'm not [ __ ] doing that
so uh i had to pick an era where he was
actually wearing a shirt which is it's
not easy
it's not easy to find but anyway so uh i
did that and then i went last night i
went down to the comedy store and um
they had actually had a uh a memorial
service for robin williams
and uh it was awesome man it was
you know
just like
so many people from back in the day came
out
that were down there i actually i'm
wondering when all the last time all of
that group of people were down there
um and they were all telling stories it
was like i got there late unfortunately
but uh norm mcdonald
yakov schmearnoff had some great stories
uh
jackson purdue
then uh there's a couple people that
were in part of his improv group
we're all telling all these great
stories and uh it was a really great
thing but i gotta tell you man that was
i i it's
not like i knew the guy or anything but
that was brutal
[ __ ] brutal
when i heard the news about that one
that one really uh
you know there's one of those things
where you really you think you know yeah
i love that guy i love his movies i i
think that guy's hilarious she you know
you don't realize it and then something
like that happens just like wow man i
had no idea how much that guy uh
affected me i did get a chance um
one time
to do a show with him
uh he always um
you know he would just come down to
clubs i'd always heard about i know he
did it he lived up in san francisco but
people were saying like yeah there's
this open mic he went to every single
week
um bartnik told this great story about
uh how he was at a concert
he was kind of like the like the
unofficial mayor of like san francisco
when you they needed like a laugh or
something like i guess
bartnik was at some big concert and uh
it was an outdoor thing and it rained
and um you know so i apologize everybody
the bands can't go on everybody's
standing [ __ ] looking like a bunch of
[ __ ]
wet shelter dogs and stuff and
robin williams was in the crowd and
he just went up on stage
in like a [ __ ] rain poncho
and did 45 minutes
in front of an uh a soaking wet angry
crowd that wasn't getting their show and
he crushed just did like a headlining
set
and uh and then in the end like the sun
was coming out and he's like all right
the bands are coming out blah blah blah
just went right back into the crowd you
see it was like a zillion stories like
that that i heard and um
so anyways i was doing uh jeff garland
had this show
he does uh every now and again down at
the ucb
and uh
it's this really cool format in the end
he has like this improv game called uh
the combo platter
and it's basically they pick a subject
and
each person has to go up and riff on it
for five minutes and then you sit down
and then the next round is you go back
up again but
anybody can interrupt anybody at any
time and it just starts going you just
start adding to whatever they're doing
and when
you know one night i went down there and
i was doing the show with them and robin
showed up
and garland knew him and everything and
they went in with the show and i
actually got to do improv standing right
next to him doing improv i literally
felt like i was on comic relief
you know i mean we're sitting in the
chairs right this is like such a [ __ ]
weird moment but we always sit in the
chair next to him you know we had that
thick arm hair it's like we were the
space between us was a little tight but
it wasn't anywhere where we still should
have been touching but his arm hair was
so [ __ ] thick it actually was
it actually was touching my arm i had to
move my arm
i remember thinking all those jokes that
he used to do about how he felt like he
was wearing a sweater and all that type
of thing but it was one of obviously one
of the great things i ever got to do and
fortunately
because he was such an open guy and such
a nice guy
sweet guy he didn't didn't
you know come in with that you know i've
been doing this forever
get out of the way kid he didn't have
that vibe at all he was like a really
vulnerable kind of vibe
that because he came with that vibe i
was actually able to like enjoy it as it
was happening
rather than um
look back on it and be like uh yeah i
got to do that but i i was so in my head
i had to like knock him down you know
that's like something i have to do
sometimes when i get a gig that's so big
i literally have to to develop a certain
level of hatred for this person that i
don't hate i have to be like you know
[ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this guy for making
me feel so [ __ ] uncomfortable with
this
it's success or whatever but
the way robin was you didn't have to do
that when you're around him so uh
you know thanks to jeff garland for
[ __ ]
you know having that show so i could
have that memory but it's definitely a
huge huge
huge [ __ ] uh indescribable uh
loss and um
that just sucks i hate that it ends that
way
you know
so anyways isn't that happy isn't that
happy to [ __ ] have to talk about that
yet another [ __ ] person in this
business you know what was [ __ ]
weird is i got like three
texts within 24 hours of robin's death
you know
asking me if i was okay and then telling
me not to kill myself
and that just struck me as funny like
it's like depression and suicide are not
like us
like
like a stand-up like if a [ __ ]
plumber kills himself it do people reach
out to other plumbers hey man i know you
haven't got a lot of sinks lately it's
been mostly toilets and uh you know just
reaching out that you know it's it's
going to turn around you know
you know
um
look i'm not a [ __ ] doctor but i know
that that [ __ ] um
it definitely uh
it definitely affects
you know a lot of people i mean i've
dealt with you know unfortunately
and it's been people outside of uh
stand-up
let's see i gotta like count i think
it's
three
yeah three people that i know
you know committed suicide
it's [ __ ] brutal man it's it's really
[ __ ] brutal and uh
so i got this
you know i don't know
i see somebody start go down at the
depress road
it's just [ __ ] it's so hard to get
him off it
um
i don't know
all i know is it sucks
so
back to the podcast anyways what am i
going to talk about this week um
oh let's let's just continue with like
you know talking about depression and
suicide can i can i [ __ ] just openly
and honestly talk about the ice bucket
challenge
can i do that without [ __ ] this
mccarthyism [ __ ] error
of once the ball gets rolling if you
[ __ ] go anywhere else you're not
supporting the troops you [ __ ] you're
a
you're you're a commie you you hate
women or you know it just
that ice bucket challenge i've at this
point i've been challenged by three
different [ __ ] people
okay
the last one was last night
and it's
this is this is what uh
the person texts me said hey you know go
check out my ice bucket challenge i love
how it's about the person
it's so not even about the disease hey
check out my wacky response to ice cold
water over my [ __ ] head
and he goes uh
what the hell is it he said
it's on facebook
um
hope you're good i nominated you for the
ice bucket
als challenge so i wrote back i said
listen dude i live in a desert
all right it's a 500
fine if you waste water i'm gonna do the
hundred dollar donation instead
so he goes you prick well played you can
do it on the road and send me the video
and i wrote back i'm like dude it's
about raising money for als
not what not you watching me dump
a bucket of ice over my [ __ ] head
i don't underst
like do you understand how precious
water is
to everybody and around the world how
much there's a shortage of it we're over
here going
just dumping it over our heads
and it's to the point now it's the
disease is is
second banana
to watching somebody's reaction i know
it's a fun [ __ ] thing and it's raised
over 100 million dollars and all of that
type of [ __ ]
but uh
there's this pressure like if you don't
[ __ ] do it and you just give a
hundred bucks somehow you're an [ __ ]
what i want to know is how many people
just dump the bucket of ice over their
head and it's another [ __ ] you know
me moment for them and then they don't
even give any goddamn money
um
you know this is just gonna open a can
of worm for all these other diseases
there's actually people in foundations
right now sitting in a boardroom
okay with [ __ ]
bagels and cream cheese sitting in front
of them then everybody wants to go and
grab but no one wants to grab it first
so they seem like the person who just
came there to eat and they are sitting
there brainstorming trying to figure out
how can we come up with our own ice
bucket challenge
so people give a [ __ ] about rickets
[Applause]
you know it's like when there's a hit
[ __ ] movie
oh my god it's a hit movie with vampires
god damn it put vampires in everything
that's what's gonna happen
what other natural resource can we use
uh
fred the fresh air challenge
the aquifer
ice bucket challenge everybody's got to
go to [ __ ] nantucket and dump water
over their head
i don't know
i don't know it's a good thing because
it's raising money but i got to be
honest with you
you know
there's not a lot of water left people
if you really look at
the only fresh water we got coming is
the polar ice caps melting
do you know a lot of those blue blood
cuts are going around the world and
they're buying up property that sits on
an aquifer because they know that water
in the future is going to be equivalent
to currency
do you understand
how much little information i had before
i just made that unbelievably terrifying
statement do you understand that people
why are you listening to this thing
um
you know what's going to be a rough
month is the ice bucket challenge
and then also the pink month in the nfl
all of these [ __ ] things oh man i i
really hope i just hope that the money
actually gets to the people that need it
uh
you know
because
that p the lady from when i from what
i've i've actually read on the internet
so god knows if it's even remotely true
she makes like three quarters of a
million dollars a year
and i know she's raised a bunch of money
and all that type of [ __ ] but at the end
of the day
if there weren't a bunch of women dying
from breast cancer
she wouldn't have a job it's just
[ __ ] weird i guess it's you can say
the same thing about a doctor but a
doctor is trying to
well i guess she's trying to get him
better
i don't know how do you justify pulling
that kind of money
i guess you're sitting there going like
well i raised a hundred million dollars
that's not even one percent i took three
quarters of one percent
then again three-quarters of a million
dollars you're probably riding around a
bmw
i bet that isn't painted pink easy is it
you know you want to make sure you got
the resale value don't you
what's the name of the lady that does
the pink thing is it pam is it peggy
does her name start with p
um all right anyways this is the monday
morning podcast everybo everybody a
really heavy one we've talked about
suicide als and uh
breast
cancer
hey how excited are you guys that the
nfl football is coming back the nfl
football hall do i sign you know
is she on that internet
um
all right legalzoom.com everybody
most americans don't have a will
but why
you don't want the court dictating what
happens to you
or your property or your minor children
it didn't say you there you're dead so
that doesn't make any sense bill read it
correctly you don't want the court
dictating what happens to your property
and your minor children so why
procrastinate you know what most people
say they go oh it's too expensive or
it's too time consuming dude you know
what my answer is to that legalzoom.com
too expensive legalzooms prices they
just make sense too time-consuming look
it only takes 20 minutes and legalzoom
guides you from start to finish the
service was developed by some of the
best legal minds in the country and they
make it painless for you to get the
legal help you need in fact helping
people get legally protected has been
their mission and passion for over 13
years during the national make a will
month get special pricing on wills and
living trusts by entering bur b-u-r-r in
the referral box at checkout again that
discount code is burr b-u-r-r it's
national make a will month so don't wait
protect your family protect your future
at legalzoom.com today legalzoom was
developed by top attorneys top attorneys
top attorneys to provide self-help
services at your specific direction but
they are not a law firm legalzoom is hel
his legal help is furnished through
vetted independent attorneys
legalzoom.com discount code burr burr
all right man of classic here
dollar shave club everybody
have you ever ever wondered why raises
are so expensive big shave companies are
charging you for ridiculous shave
technology you don't even need
first vibrating handles net what's next
a flashlight huh now pivot flex ball
heads what's next mv mp3 players
i mean come on people enough is enough
join dollarshaveclub.com for a few bucks
a month dollar shave club delivers the
world's best razors
raises right to your door i think dollar
shave club blades are better than the
big company shave uh big the big shave
companies for a fraction of the price
it's the same blade
you know what is it made out of aluminum
the thing's dull in like five shaves
it's just they're giving you the same
blade that they charge you like what
nine hundred dollars for
for uh for a fraction of the price i
don't know the price is here i'm going
to get to it then the copy anyways it's
so easy go to
dollarshaveclub.com pick one of their
razors they start at three dollars a
month
fresh blade every week you're out of
your mind if you don't do this you don't
even have to go to the damn store you
don't need the bank you don't break the
bank you don't have to resort to cheap
disposable to ship to save cash
dollarshave.com.com is amazing this is a
train wreck read every month they ship
you
automatic deliveries you'll never forget
to buy blades again you don't have to
squeeze shaves out of a dull dirty old
razor blade
uh you get to have you get to shave with
the fresh blade every week this is
absolutely mandatory for anyone
uh that wants a great shave you deserve
better than a dull old blade don't you
why don't you treat yourself no more
ridiculous shave technology make the
smarter choice like i did join the
dollar shave club revolution at
dollarshaveclub.com b-u-r-r that's
dollarshaveclub.com
i want to get some complaints on that
one it's not that you insulted us it's
that you read it so bad no one can
understand what you're saying
e-voice everybody
if you take all your business calls
yourself it's pretty hard to look
professional get anything done
by helping you expertly manage all of
your business calls e-voice provides you
a better way to connect with your
clients with toll-free number
professional voice greeting and a dial
by name directory e-voice transforms any
phone into your business phone when
customers call they're automatically
sent to wherever you are you can be at
home the office a sitting poolside with
a cold beverage you'll always sound like
you're a fortune 500 company and you'll
get all of this for under 13 bucks a
month
for a limited time my listeners can try
evoice for free for 60 days that's right
60 days but this extended trial will not
last forever you have to do it now go to
evoice.com and enter promo code bill
upon checkout to get your special offer
make sure you hurry because this offer
ends soon go to evoice.com promo code
bill that's evoice.com promo code bill
bravo india lima lima all right sorry
all right let's get back to the podcast
here um
let's get back to diseases and talking
about dying or whatever um
i'm calling 2072 for me i want to see
the 70s again
that's why i'm trying to uh well that's
not why i'm trying to eat right and
exercise i do it because i'm vain
you know
i just want to look good for you people
that's my new ending to the crying you
like that one
that's when i take it to another level
that long one makes versey [ __ ] laugh
his ass off oh jesus who is this
no it's my brother
hey i'm doing my podcast can i call you
right back
all right cool
um
bum bum
you know what's funny is silly is that
that [ __ ] ringtone sounds like if you
gave that to anybody in asia
they would start with that thing and
then they would have like the most
amazing they could build that theme
into the sickest [ __ ] like opening to
an olympic ceremony ever you've ever
seen
you like that
that's called positive stereotypes
that music sounded asian to me so i
connected it with asian culture with uh
a positive result
is that also offensive
you know what i mean
if you just say stereotypical [ __ ] but
it's positive
dude let me tell you something about
those grease ball italians they can
really cook they're the best cooks in
the world like do you have some sort of
weird like mcdlt
like hot and cold you throw in something
[ __ ] offensive and then with the big
time like positive thing
all those [ __ ] can't drive but whoa
are they good at math
okay we're like fifth he needs to like
half apologize and like almost get
suspended
i'm sorry
let's get back to the uh to the podcast
um
where the hell am i
oh dude you know what i bought did i
tell you guys i late night i'm watching
tv
right
i had a lot of late nights this week
because i i had the uh it was my final
week off before i was going
uh back on the road
the oddball thing and i've really
enjoyed my time
um
time off i haven't taken time off in um
i don't know [ __ ] 10 years
like took a significant period of time
off um
just sort of been doing this [ __ ]
because it's been fun but at some point
i kind of looked up and was like hey i
need to i need to chill out so the last
you know july and august i kind of
you know rather than going out every
other weekend and
one or two back-to-back weekends i kind
of did like
well i did still did two weekends in
july but they were fun weekends and i
haven't done [ __ ] in august yet
and um
it's been great
i've been in la building up my new hour
and uh i was [ __ ] around last night
down at the comedy store
which uh
you know is my favorite club out here
and um it was another great thing
because you when you go into the comedy
store the original room that's where
all those guys
um
when they came to town that's where they
they went up i don't even know that they
had the main room initially
they just had that uh the original room
and that's where letterman leno
robin williams uh sam kinnison dice all
of those guys sandra sander bernhard all
of them
all of the comedy store greats
jim carrey all those guys started there
and uh so they have these neon signs
that they made for like some of their
best
ones and it was basically it's prior
uh kennison robin williams
um
i forget you just go around the room
it's like you know
it's like five mount rushmores with the
people so last night you went in there
and they usually have them all lit up
and they only had robins lit up was
really [ __ ] cool
and i wanted to try out a bunch of new
stuff so i'm like well [ __ ] there's a
sign right there robin williams the king
of [ __ ] improv so
i've just been going down there
and um
you know as every hour starts out with
it starts off with that idea that little
chunk
and i've been [ __ ] around with the
order and i just went up there and i was
did like 15 minutes nothing from my
special
there was a couple of
leftover ideas that didn't get developed
or didn't make the special for whatever
reason not like i made a choice for them
not to be in the special they just
didn't come out you know i just did my
act and
those jokes didn't get told so
um
just been having a great [ __ ] time
being home
um
and
i don't know now i'm getting ready to do
the [ __ ] road and i'm literally
having like a panic attack
like ah [ __ ] i gotta go back out there
again but i know the second i get out
there it's gonna be great
and uh i'm really looking forward to
these oddball shows because uh
one i need the [ __ ] money i haven't
worked in two months
and uh i got the downstairs
hanging over my goddamn head
um you know what kills me is we put in
this this we put in this walk-in closet
right
downstairs
um off this bathroom
and you know it's an old house so it's
it's a walk-in closet the size of how
fat people are today and how much extra
[ __ ] we buy compared to back in the day
when people you know used to take [ __ ]
down to the cobbler or get the tv
repaired the tv repairman was actually a
[ __ ] career you know you didn't just
keep buying [ __ ] and then
going to goodwill and throwing it at
them and then buying more [ __ ]
so anyways um i basically
this is how [ __ ] hilarious women are
and how much faster their [ __ ] brains
are
in certain areas when we came and we
looked at this house
i was just
i don't know what i was looking at i
just liked it
and
when we left the house
she was just like what'd you think i was
like i don't know i like that one and
she kind of went like i liked it too and
then we got like excited but she had
already worked out what room was going
to be hers and which closets were going
to be hers
and i have like
i got like two
half a closets
you know
back when like someone who was like
foreclosed for like back when somebody
was my size
he was considered like
i don't know what
like i would be in like the in the early
days of the nba at 5 10
170 175 i don't know what you know
on a [ __ ] franchise i could have
actually been a power forward
i'm just saying people were smaller back
then if you don't realize that go to an
old stadium whatever's left the yale
bowl to the rose bowl you the cotton
bowl you go out to those old stadiums
and what's hilarious is they're a third
of the size of the new stadiums
and they hold more people they hold like
a hundred thousand people now a lot of
that is because there's not luxury boxes
and all that [ __ ] space where they
have people walking around but when
you're sitting down where they have the
numbers on the aluminum benches it's
like
they used to be back in the old patriots
stadium
if you stood up during the winter when
everybody had that puffy coats on during
an exciting play if you were the last
person to try to sit down in your row
you lost your seat and you had to kind
of crouch down and wait for something
else
good to happen is people threw [ __ ] at
you you know in a joking way going down
in front knowing
what the deal was
um so anyway so i have i have like these
two like one of the closets i have is so
[ __ ] small
like um it's basically
from it's my shoulder width
and it's it's long and it's that wide
and
up top it has like some almost like it's
not baseboard it's not the middle of the
wall and then it has what i hang my
clothes on
are you know like nunchuck handles just
imagine nunchuck handles being twice the
size of that and there's three of those
and i i set them on that baseboard
that's not a baseboard
halfway up the wall
at a 45 degree angle there's three of
them and then i hang clothes on them and
what happens is inevitably i reach when
i have to grab something in the second
row if i go to pull it off if i pull it
off too quickly the whole thing falls
down and takes down another row
um so anyways
anyways when we i gotta say this quietly
because she's in the other room when we
started this [ __ ] project
okay that
walk-in closet downstairs that was going
to be
mostly mine
and partly hers but it was going to be
mostly mine
and i don't know what happened during
the [ __ ] project but like
i i've lost real estate down there again
i i
i swear to god and now i'm actually you
know what i'm thinking i'm like i need
to redo the garage
and i'm like there it is
there it is
i'm the stereotypical guy
i have i'm gradually being squeezed out
of my house and i'm going to i just do a
bit about that
then when you get married all your [ __ ]
ends up in either the basement or the
garage we don't have a basement
but we have a garage so
and this is the funny thing i'm actually
looking forward to it because it's not
attached to the house
so i could just kind of have that you
know
i can walk away from my life that is
actually was
a fantasy of mine
like my dream house
you know if i wasn't in this [ __ ]
business was i would live out more in
the country
not literally the country but i would
live in a place that looked like the
country but was still like a 45-minute
drive to a major city
and i always wanted
um
i always like old houses because i make
everything in my [ __ ] life difficult
you know rather than just buying a new
one i just i like old [ __ ] so i i would
buy an old house fix the whole thing up
but it would have a
a garage
with a room over the garage that is is
detached from the house
ideally it's an old barn
and
down below
i would have my old truck
and then i would have some selfish
vehicle like a [ __ ] corvette some
two-seater
like [ __ ] you people i know i'm married
but you know i need some me time and
then upstairs i'd have my drums guitars
and all of that [ __ ]
you know and then you know of course a
flat screen tv and if let's let's just
go all out a [ __ ] refrigerator
right
with like uh
you know
all kinds of booze in there
humidor cigars
you know fire escape up the back for
[ __ ]
whatever you get the idea
[Music]
um
so now i'm thinking
you know i got this garage
i mean not like i'm going to put another
floor on it but uh
eventually i'm actually at this point
because of my situation in my house my
lack of closet space
and the fact that i bought this old
ludwig drum kit
with john bonham size drums like a 26
inch bass drum it's [ __ ] huge
um that i'm actually thinking of uh
eventually
i don't know
redoing the i'm more excited to redo the
garage than i am the kitchen
put it that way
because uh that's how it works
that's how it works by the way somebody
sent me a um
somebody sent me a text of uh
mel gibson's divorce settlement
um
and you know what's funny the first half
of it didn't even bother me
he was worth like 800 million
he's been with his wife for 30 years she
gave him seven [ __ ] kids
okay
seven
kids
so she gets half that fortune you know
what i don't got a problem with that
[ __ ] it
you know i'll take 400 million take who
gives a [ __ ] at that point
you had seven kids
god bless you here you go
i'll give you 500 million i'll keep 300
million what [ __ ] killed me
is she gets half
of all of his checks for the rest of her
life the rest of mel's life
and that's that's that extra [ __ ] like
it's like come on man he just gave you
400 million dollars
you can't you
can't like survive
on that for the rest of your life
you got to go after that but i guess
what it is is really it isn't even about
the money it's more about i gave you 30
years of my [ __ ] life
okay i absolutely blew out my [ __ ]
body for you
and now you're gonna go get
with this russian [ __ ]
and what am i going to do
i wanted to hang with you for the rest
of my life you don't want to enjoy our
golden years and now i got to go to a
[ __ ] bingo parlor to find somebody
else yeah maybe i get it
maybe i get it
but i gotta be honest somebody sent me
that that uh
or tweeted it to me and i read it and it
actually was keeping me up at night
last night thinking about that uh
but i always end up finding the positive
i was just like you know what i would
just completely 100
downsize my life and i would live like
i'd have one fork one spoon one knife
one ball one plate one glass
i would just make everything super
[ __ ] simple
um
i dress like [ __ ] albert einstein
you know i would have the same [ __ ]
outfit
every goddamn day i would just make it
ridiculously simple
um
yeah and then i'd live in i get a flat
screen and a [ __ ] pull out couch and
i would just have uh all the sports
packages and a dog and that would be it
and i would just keep it like that and
i'd drive my old truck that would be it
i would just that would be it that would
be my [ __ ] life
i wear chuck taylors
i would just keep it simple
that actually doesn't sound like a bad
life does it
i mean even that life that's how spoiled
i am
living in a first world country like
that's my
you know did you hear what happened to
bill
he has a place to live
and can watch sports 24 hours a day and
he has a dog
and he has his health the poor bastard
all right um
let's get to uh the last advertising
read here all right this read it's
prosper everybody
prosper
in 72 hours you could have thirty five
thousand dollars to cover your needs
what will you do pay off a high
uh pay off a high rate credit card start
a business that home improvement project
i can tell you right now even if you did
that a lateral move
where rather than owing the credit card
company you owed prosper if their
interest is lower right there you just
saved money and all you did was just
move money from this hand to this hand
oh what did i do there what did i do
there
um
with our sponsor prosper it's never been
easier go online answer a few questions
and see how low fixed
how your low fixed rate and see your low
fixed rate in seconds
jesus bill your money hits your account
and as few as three days prospers the
fastest growing peer-to-peer lender and
they facilitated over one billion
dollars in loans for people like you
their revolutionary platform connects
people looking to borrow money with
those who have money to invest there's
no outrages fees no raising interest
rates and you'll never set foot in a
bank just go to prosper.com
b-u-r-r to check out your rate instantly
without affecting your credit score
that's always nice huh
for a limited time prosper is offering
my listeners a fifty dollar visa
prepaid gift card
when you get a loan
go to prosper.com
uh up to 35 thousand dollars in just
three days and a fifty dollar gift card
go to
prosper.com other restrictions apply
seed site for details gift card is
issued by
central state bank of florida
pursuant to license from visa usa
incorporated all personal loans are made
by web bank a utah charted chartered
industrial bank member fdic
equal housing lender
all right
um so that's the advertising for this
week
let's get back to the podcast um
oh my god so i didn't mention i was up
late night
and uh i was watching uh you know
having a couple of drinks
this was months and months ago
and it was it was one of those time life
like music collections and it was this
easy listening rock
this easy listening rock music that they
had and they just had like two former
stars and then going who can forget this
one you know the music of our childhood
is so important absolutely randy and
it's timeless what about this bg song
right
shadow dancing or whatever the [ __ ] they
were singing i can't for some reason i'm
going blank on all the [ __ ] songs so
long story short i actually bought the
box set
and uh i've just been driving around
listening to this [ __ ] soft rock
maybe if you want me
baby if you need me
you're the only one i'm just all of this
[ __ ]
so they actually had a doobie brothers
song saturday in the park and i realized
that
as a comedian my bucket list is i want
to be in the city of boston at karaoke
and i want to listen to somebody sing
that song just for the first line
in the park
people in boston don't really say say
they say saturday
lunch come over on saturday
hey mia's in here a man selling ice
cream
singing italian songs
you gotta admit that how great is that
it's a good it's very positive and
uplifting but was he really just in the
park on a saturday and just wrote a song
about the things that he was observing
because it really sounds like that
people dancing people laughing a man
selling ice cream
singing italian songs
[Laughter]
anyways and of course are you talking
about your your box set that you got
drunk at one in the morning yeah
what what what are some of the other
songs that were on there
it was like didn't they have like air
supply on there and linda ron stands and
linda ron sent doing the smoke you're so
vain that's that i bet you
song is about you right yeah all that
all that stuff this soft rock
but you know what actually these like
eight cd sets
remember this from the you know
oh absolutely and i'll tell you right
now
one of my favorite things was this next
guy what was that guy rupert something
or other rupert holmes him
oh him a song i have never heard of in
my entire life that was a filler song
then they also had all these songs from
the 80s it kind of bothered me
uh that they actually actually they had
a couple of uh but this is stuff that
you would find on like a
like a easy listening type of like old
school soft rock station right i think
it's just because four seven the wave
exactly
but i have like a line drawn in the sand
as far as like 70s and 80s because to me
why
because i just think as you go from
decade to decade it's just such a
jarring change because whoever's coming
up if they're gonna make it
you know if you try to do that more of
the same you're literally
going to try to
float on the fumes of this other style
that's going out you got to change so
that disco went into like new wave into
into that
metal music into grunge
and then rap took over and like not like
rap wasn't around but like
it i i just i don't know so for me like
that 70s like how do you put in like
with saturday in the park how do you put
in like genesis or mike in the mechanics
in the living years
because i think it's just all sort of i
never talked to my dad
he was a [ __ ] dick
but he bought me a bicycle general genre
of just like soft not too hard
oh say loud
back up black singers to make me sound
like i have soul you better not be
referring to michael mcdonald because he
is a national treasure i was talking
about mike in the mechanics who's that
oh no i've heard of him he was the he
was the bearded guy
who looked like the father on family
ties but he was actually in genesis
oh okay
i know what the father of family ties
look like
that's an awesome song that song you
know some people your age 10 years
younger than me think that song is
awesome because
no because you were having awesome
memories yeah when that song came out
you didn't have to pay for anything you
know you went to school like your big
thing was like oh my god i have a pimple
on my face like like your life was easy
why can't i just like a song because i
like a song because that song sucks does
it really it's so fun
is this when people decided that they
didn't like phil collins because he went
into like no this is when people were
loving everything that he was doing okay
they forgot see the one thing people
forget about phil collins is uh that guy
is one of the greatest drummers of the
last 40 years he's a [ __ ] insane
drummer
and
genesis initially was this progressive
rock band
uh had peter gabriel it was just
monsters in this band
and then they
trimmed down like all of them after a
while it's just like man let's just get
[ __ ] paid man
let's stop doing 20 minute jams wait
who's that band that their video is
hilarious because they're on some sort
of boardwalk and they're playing
like they're miming playing instruments
even though they know how to do it
that's journey yeah oh wait it says
someday love will find you break those
chains that bite you
yeah yeah and they're [ __ ] sitting
there sorry
when the concepts for when they first
started making videos are just you just
see how they're just throwing everything
against the wall and just seeing what
works they're like how about we play
with no instruments man let's try to
make it interesting
um
it's like why would you why would you do
that but they thought it was a really
cool
concept at the time but 80s videos are
the best they're so much fun another
another phil collins one this is solo
phil collins that you love that's on
this collection that who can forget
these songs who can forget this hit was
uh that song uh take a look at me now
yeah yeah ugh that song's awful
because i have a gun in my mouth
and even though i'm a rock star and i
can get a bunch of [ __ ] you really
didn't i can't stop thinking about your
fold
you can't you there's really no need
there's there's really no need for you
to take it to that dark place okay he is
that is it is a dark place i went to the
they had the [ __ ] they had the
memorial for robin williams it's a sad
[ __ ] time and that song will make you
put a [ __ ] gun in your mouth i mean
it is pretty depressing thank you okay
fair enough see that that's why you're
the [ __ ]
why because i eventually agree with you
no because if you're wrong you admit it
yeah it is depressing but it's beautiful
at the same time but it's very sad it is
some it is definitely something you
listen to in the dark crying and
drinking alone i don't i drive down this
street like rooting for phil come on get
your [ __ ] together you sound like you're
on her front lawn look at me now look at
what you did to me and then she's doing
it's an empty space she's dating some
bigger dude
take care of that guy
no i'll hand it i'll handle it philip
you have to stop coming over stop i told
you i moved on and you coming back to me
philip i've called the police okay
he's got a hatchback with all his [ __ ]
in the back poor phil collins these dumb
tennis shoes that don't have [ __ ]
laces in them how is phil collins these
days there was an article written about
him i feel like in rolling stone a few
years ago yeah it was really the
angriest man in rock or something no no
i wasn't angry he was just he was uh he
was in a bad place he was going through
like his third [ __ ] divorce
and physically he couldn't play drums
anymore but i think he's come out of
that
and he was also
couldn't understand why he was
considered the antichrist by a lot of
music fans why was he cons that's what i
was wondering that's that's why i was
saying earlier wasn't there a period
where people decided that they hated him
why because there's this tipping seated
yeah but there's this tipping point
where you become so successful and you
have so much money
and
when the next group of people comes up
and they rebel
against that era like in in the 80s
disco sucked
all right into the 60s were the coolest
[ __ ] thing ever and then the 90s came
and then the 90s it was like the 70s
were [ __ ] cool boogie nights and all
that [ __ ] and then the 80s were like uh
you know that was all cheesy horseshit
and hair metal and all that [ __ ] crap
so
he got so big he defined that era kind
of like the bee gees
so i think now it's coming back around
where people like him like you like him
joe derosa
the teen sensation the teen idol
sensation from the opium anthony program
he uh
he
he loves phil collins
um oh he's actually gonna be down the
the goddamn comedy jam tonight oh is he
yeah very good is he gonna is he gonna
jam man he's gonna sing oh my god this
is incredible i'm very excited for it oh
you know how you know how i love our son
joe derosa
as we used to call him we lived in new
york he's always yeah we had we'd
haven't come over for dinner
bill and i kind of adopted joe
when we all lived in new york
yeah and you two guys the way you guys
would eat like steak to the point you
would eat when you get a rib eye you'd
be eating all the gristle too like i
never saw that it was like running that
john candy movie where he had he had to
eat the the thing the fat
he was eating that that that big steak
or whatever it is and yeah the 72 ounces
yeah no joe and i like to get we didn't
like to get right down into it joe said
he would eat the bones if he could okay
well i'm not going to go that far but
yeah you got to get all the meat off
that bone baby hey go go grab another
mic so i don't have to keep passing it
over to you go grab another mic with the
chord and all that and i'm going to read
one of these questions here okay um oh
hey this is a good thing here
i want to thank the listeners everybody
went out and downloaded nick youssef's
all things comedy remember
part of the part of the mob here uh the
podcast mob
um
who uh downloaded his uh his comedy
album last last week everybody was
really pleased a lot of people hadn't
heard about nick
he's underground you want to be the
first person on your block to say hey i
know about this cool new comedian
um seriously man this guy's the real
deal in his uh his car his album made it
to number three on itunes how about that
hey uh the the microphones in the uh
it's in the closet my half a closet that
i have nene
what do you mean oh god
can we talk about that nia how how i
walked in and just loved this house you
walked in loved this house and also
picked out all the choice spots it was
[ __ ] amazing how you were able to do
that
how did you do that
how can you just take all the [ __ ]
closets and leave me leave me without a
space thing first
for my [ __ ] shirts and my damn socks
all the spots are for you
we have a closet [ __ ]
i really don't appreciate that
we both have the same kind of closet
space in the bedroom so no that's equal
okay you want to trade closets what do
you mean in this this area well no i
mean i have all my stuff settled right
now how brilliant was that
she literally gives herself time do you
what you want to trade do you want to
trade closets what do you mean all of a
sudden you don't understand english
i understand excuse me
don't insult me don't don't don't play
the i'm offended card it has no okay you
know exactly what's going on i have half
a [ __ ] closet that's hanging off this
house that is not up to code and it has
a piece of [ __ ] wood holding it up i
told you that i would help you go to the
container store and figure out how to
organize your [ __ ] the way that i did
that's what i did you saw it took me
like three months to figure it all out
and get it all in there perfectly i told
you i could help you with way to god and
you don't have patience for you you
don't have to pay your lionface
[Laughter]
all right i told you i would help you
out okay so you don't have patience for
that sort of thing
and you know
are you done with your horseshit
both of your closets you can walk into
you can walk in to that one and watch
stand sideways i i can't really you know
what i can do in my closets
i can do that hammer time dance in both
of my closets
and you know what either the back of my
head or my little button nose is going
to scrape on the wall and i did say
button nose i have a cute nose on my
giant face
i thought i was the one with the cute
nose oh you know something you took all
the closet spades can i at least be the
one with the cute nose okay there we go
you can have them you know bad i'm gonna
get trash for that on the podcast i'm
looking for he makes cookies
hey
yes so now we're gonna don't start yes
dear and me that downstairs closet
that'll be done in 2016.
that is mine
um i think we're gonna share it is
really what we've i don't like the way
you share
what is that what are you talking about
i'm gonna have this closet up here i'm
only putting down we have two closets
upstairs and you can walk into and do a
little dance make a little love
get down tonight who can forget this one
who can forget this one let's get to the
uh let's get to the uh the questions for
the week homeless with the plan dear
boxcar billy that's good
[Laughter]
that's actually really good if you found
yourself homeless tomorrow what would
you what would be your game plan oh my
god where would you set up shop
are you an under the bridge guy that's
the first thing i thought of or a beach
guy i'm definitely not a beach guys do
you sleep all day to be alert to the
dangers of the night oh is that what
they do yeah makes sense that makes
complete sense yeah the ones who can't
fight
um
they sleep during the day i think that's
also just common sense though actually
you know what they're like they're like
rabbits
what does that mean rabbits are like the
cute and furry but vicious no rabbits
are just like uh
they exist
to keep everything else fed
in nature that's why they [ __ ] like
rabbits they can have a bunch of them
they're like coleslaw
on the uh the meat platter oh [ __ ]
hate coleslaw really is like a filler it
fills up the plate but i actually was
defending coleslaw to paul verzi it's
like when somebody knows how to make it
so many people don't know how to make it
they make it all wet and [ __ ]
man-easy yeah too much mayonnaise what
about our old neighbor though he made
ahaha he made the [ __ ] uh he made the
hearty one yeah he made it very like
crisp and it's more like vinegary and
tangy jason lawhead makes an
unbelievable [ __ ] uh coleslaw he
makes like his but jason longhead can
cook anything and can make a meal out of
anything that's right well let me let me
finish this right here okay do you sleep
all day to be alert to the danger of the
night uh you could beg or play drums on
some pots and pants
thanks for the last uh listener from new
hampshire new hampshire oh i'll tell you
new hampshire that's god's country up
there
that was did you still have the time
we ever took like a little vacation
together do you remember that was in new
hampshire in the captain's quarters
captains quarters
that little like beach lake type
business they've got over there uh
anyway i could see you uh that was great
that was great and it was like it was
perfect white trash for me
there's enough tatted up people with
tank tops there was enough [ __ ] uh
just sort of ate mac and cheese as a
main course meal like me with toast
remember when i tried to
like spray that kind of like tinter tint
spf on you it was supposed to like
supposed to give you like a tan and it
didn't work and i used it i remember
that you used like two [ __ ] spray
cans and nothing happened it wasn't it
just wouldn't take like your your your
skin repels color like it's resistant to
cut like it just won't happen for you it
won't happen
yeah it just won't you get so you get
more freckles
on like your forearms and like your
lower legs but other than that it's
nothing
well what happens is if my so who can't
take like a spray tan essentially like
what kind of pasty melon and deficient
[ __ ] piece of freak nature are you
that you can't even i'm being so mean
right now no you're not i don't give a
[ __ ] it's true
i will object you notice i didn't
interrupt you i will i will object when
you say something that isn't accurate
all right so obviously sleeping during
the day is going to be rough for me
because of the sun so i either choose a
beat down or i get sunburned so
definitely gotta do you gotta do the
bridge it's it's shadier
for you but it also it also smells like
urine
so
you know you gotta take the good with
the baby
um and hoof can forget this impactful
hit
um
you know i used to i used to play drums
with this guy and he was into the chili
and
peppers
we used to play this song that was
really fun to play but i hated the
lyrics
all right
suck my kiss
oh okay i hate
you shook my kiss
[Laughter]
[ __ ] hated the lyrics
uh yeah that's a rough one realize i
don't want to be a miser
the best thing about the red hot chili
peppers is
the whole band is awesome i love anthony
cutis i liked it you hated his [ __ ]
what
his hitler mustache not his hitler
mustache
his autobiography where it was just one
and then i was banging this hot chick
and i was in love and yeah no i found it
then i had it it's insufferable i found
insufferable i like david and you know
what he came up to me like a bully and
he was mean to flee and i was like this
guy's a dick and flea needs to know how
to draw some [ __ ] lines and be like
listen anthony i'm not putting up with
that [ __ ] i think flea knows how to take
care of himself just fine please see him
scrappy
and like he's a little rapper but you
know what he wears his heart on his
sleeve that's what i got out of it
oh please no probably let's turn into a
flea love fest flea we love um you would
definitely you would be a street
performer for sure
box car billy i swear to god it's
fantastic
i would uh
you'd be able to this is what i didn't
know i would be up during the day
and i would sleep at night until i took
that first brutal ass kicking like when
the clockwork orange guys came around
started kicking me in the ribs
then i would be
a broken ribbed
balding billy sleeping on the sidewalk
like that guy down the street
when i walk cleo by cleo always funny
like you know she's always viewing
everybody as a threat she actually looks
down at this person with like this look
of concern right is he okay yeah is it
for yeah it's over and like she wants to
like sniff and stuff and and yeah like
hey buddy
is everything all right she's curious
about a lot of people it's interesting
it's been not necessarily in a bad way i
don't think i see her kind of wanting to
approach women a lot of time
yeah she's sexist so yeah i would i
would be a uh i would initially be an
under the bridge guy but i would find a
bridge that nobody else was at
um and i would also be homeless in a the
nicest neighborhood i could be in
um they'd run you out though
you can't be that's what that's a nice
neighborhood well
that's what i'm saying like the nicest
neighbor i could be homeless and
because then i could walk to a nicer
neighborhood and be like hey man can you
help me out
have a heart
and i would have every lie on my side
terminal disease homeless vet anything i
could [ __ ] think i got to make money
i do anything what do you think about
those people who are like you know why
lie i i want to get high well i didn't
mean it i'm like i liked it at first but
now i think it's hacky okay
you need to get a new you need to get a
little uh slogan there yeah clever
homeless people absolutely
all right fiance we got to get moving
here because we got to get the dog in
the uh we're already an hour and fiance
getting crazy fit
hey billy biceps
uh
today say that yeah
why you didn't like it because it was
sort of complimentary no come on how
good a shape am i in right now you look
amazing thank you uh today i have an odd
problem that i am hoping you can lend me
some advice
uh
i should have said and i'm hoping not
that i'm hope that i'm hoping uh i have
always been
on an on and off gym rat my fiance is
amazing looking and worked as a disney
world dancer which kept her in fantastic
shape recently she took a new job and
sits behind a desk all day looking for a
new way to stay fit she started heading
to the gym with me all was great for a
while to recently she found a new
workout program now she's addicted to
lifting and with the advice of a
personal trainer is looking to become a
bikini competitor sounds great right not
so much first off most bikini
competitions are crazy ripped
manly ripped
uh if i was into that
i would i would change teams
uh next issue
okay
no name i'm gonna keep going would you
want your man to look like a woman
uh next issue is that she doesn't want
to all right talk talk about my
ignorance at the end of this i realized
40 percent of why that was an ignorant
comment next issue is that she doesn't
want to have fun anymore we are in the
mid-20s no kids and live alone we
normally do a little partying which has
gotten
cut out to save all calories and last
off is that she really is a 10. now her
swinging dick in the weight room
throws lines
no no now every swinging dick in the
weight room throws lines at her every
day i trust her and have no worries but
it gets under your skin
for these selfish reasons
i could use some advice i support her no
matter what but still want her to have
fun and have no interest in dating a man
but i have no interest in dating man any
good idea maybe the lovely nia could
yell at me and set me straight you know
yeah you really have a reputation oh
yeah you're gonna you're gonna [ __ ]
get it you're absolutely gonna hey
oh aren't you the [ __ ] authority on
everything get off your oh you're gonna
get it shut up uh no i will not shut up
this guy needs to shut up because oh you
feeling a certain kind of way because
your girlfriend is you know
growing without you and you still want
to lie around and be a tub of [ __ ] no
i'm just kidding yeah
that's completely inaccurate uh i know
uh i know we know somebody that has done
bikini fitness a female and she doesn't
look like a dude at all they're the
girls that are do really the steroid
[ __ ] which is yeah that's that's that's
not a good look um and then they're the
girls who are do the natural uh thing
there's different like categories of it
but they're like the natural girls and
then they're the ones that look like
arnold schwarzenegger like circa 1983.
obviously
obviously you don't want that i totally
get that i wouldn't you know if a
girlfriend was going that direction i'd
be like ah no so of course but yeah if
she's getting in shape and she really
loves it no she's not going to want to
go out drinking
she's not going to want to go out like
that's kind of just part of it then they
don't drink water so it
sucks everything up right before the the
thing and then they go out and they
paint themselves brown
and then they go out there and they got
literally their shows shredded they had
like veins coming out of where their
bush should be yes
she's not gonna end up looking like a
dude i really don't think that that's a
real fear that you have so you really
need to stop it with that like give me a
[ __ ] break like just know that when
you're lifting weights all of a sudden
she's going to be like yo what's up like
well she has to keep the long hair
though
she has to keep the long hair because
eventually you have long hair she's
competition okay
all right because all i'm saying is
eventually if she keeps working out her
ass is going to feel like an elbow and
if she has the short hair you could
really feel like wink
that's the odds thing she's not going to
end up looking like a dude you're just
getting insecure because yeah like you
said the dudes in the weight room are
starting to talk to her and so you're
trying to deal with that by being like i
don't want to [ __ ] date a man okay i
mean calm down sweetie yeah but you know
something on the other side though we're
yourself
he cares about her he's worried he's
going to lose her you're being a douche
to him right now he's being a douche by
being like i don't want to date a guy if
i wanted that i switched jeans like
throwing that ridiculous [ __ ] in there
just come out with it just say you're
feeling insecure because she's looking
better than ever and these meathead
dudes that could probably why can't you
are now talking to jesus
that's exactly what's going on you know
nia if you want people to hear your
point you can't [ __ ] on them like that
i'm sorry did you just tell me that yeah
because that's what you do
yeah but now when i went out now these
shit's on everybody
yeah but not when i want somebody to
hear my point okay
or maybe i do oh i'm just saying well
maybe i can [ __ ] hear it from you but
i i can tell you this nia there is a
certain point where a woman gets in such
ridiculous shape you you lose a lot of
the uh femininity however you say that
[ __ ] word okay yeah you want like a
little softness yeah i understand
something that hold on to yeah and i you
know you don't want to feel like you're
cradling your buddy in a foxhole
trying to [ __ ] hold your breath
during the mustard gas that kind of
makes old willy take a [ __ ] vacation
well has i mean that's the thing though
has she even gotten to that point or is
he just like freaking out no she's going
to do the competitions yeah but as as i
said in the beginning there are
competitions where you got more of a
natural
of his feelings i validate his feelings
if he'd just be honest with his feelings
and stop though he said for these
selfish reasons okay i could use some
advice he had a sense of humor maybe he
said that maybe
yeah he's being funny okay well i'm a
little playfulness there okay all right
geez
you're getting all upset about it why
are you getting all because i want some
closet space too
this podcast theme is all about men
feeling emasculated and how you need to
get the [ __ ] over it
yeah look at that
see that what this is what i've always
said about women don't point at me i'm
pointing right at you
everything that you guys don't want us
to do to you you guys do to us in a
[ __ ] heartbeat you don't even see it
because we can beat the [ __ ] out of you
so you don't [ __ ] see you don't see
the uh the humanity in us why don't you
cue you doing that
can you add can we make that some sort
of sound effect that i can hit every
time you're like see when guys do it you
guys are like this but when you do it
it's fine i'm going to hit a button have
you go
because that's exactly what you are good
now can i do that back to you now you
see again you're always like yeah see
because this and this it's like i've
never seen like who i feel like
all right i don't know i don't know i
don't want to make it just stick your
face out i don't want it i don't want to
get racial go ahead do it do it i swear
to god [ __ ] straight white men love
trying to keep score about [ __ ] it's
like see will you guys do this we can't
do this but then that and then that it's
like you guys are fighting so hard to
maintain the status quo it's actually
laughable the kind of ridiculous things
that will come out of your mouth in
order to like keep things the way they
used to be back when this goddamn
country meant something and stood
something for something
i'm literally talking about closet space
and you turn me into some guy in
mississippi burning
you know something what you just [ __ ]
did that whole ridiculous thing of the
status quo what am i an 80 year old
republican
do you think i honestly have meetings
with my other white male straight
friends we need to talk about the status
quo
and how to maintain how to maintain it
this country is getting overrun with
feminism you know what it is
and the women who like to lift weights
and they're not they're not women
anymore god damn it put a skirt on and
get back in the kitchen
yeah
and you know what's funny is you you can
[ __ ] sit there and go off on all
these man boys with their [ __ ]
hoodies who are in their 30s and talk
all awkward and that [ __ ] huh you're
[ __ ] over there come on come on
you know what it is nia yeah yeah you
know you don't have a you don't have an
ability to step outside yourself and
just see how ridiculous and dumb you
really are is that what you're doing
you're not a smart person and nobody
likes you
all right let's go move the next one
those are the things like categorical
fish tanks did we even answer this thing
uh well why don't you answer i would
answer it this way all right
you gotta she's gonna be in great shape
which is a good thing it's better than
dating a fatty
uh
sorry
um
this is the deal i shouldn't have said
that that was extra mean i didn't mean
that but uh
she's only going to be in that gross
shape
the few days before
the competition
where she's completely [ __ ] emaciated
and actually doing damage more damage
than good to her body depriving her
vitals of of
water
um
and that awful [ __ ] tan
and
no it's gross have you seen him go out
there they they look [ __ ]
first of all they look you know they
you want to play the race card they look
raceless they all look at that terrible
shade of brown no they they look like uh
what's that [ __ ] that meat that you
eat you go and you buy a big stick of it
it's not even brown it's orange at
7-eleven beef jerky slim jim like if
beef jerky was a race that's what they
look like slim jim yeah
step into a slim jim uh but like i said
there's dif there's several different
kinds of categories of those fitness
competitions for women it's not all like
schwarzenegger style
so
just you know i don't know sorry i gave
my opinion already yeah guys don't no no
no no no where's your senator no guy
ever goes like god geez you see the
biceps on that chick
some guys like that though they like
that really like worked out
abs popping which guns blazing can i
tell you something there's somebody out
there [ __ ] a rug
okay
this you can pick up anything in the
[ __ ] world there's something that's
look at the fan over there there's
probably some guy that likes to jerk off
in front of it and feel the wind
oscillating oh my gosh
yeah there's somebody into everything
that don't make it right
i'm just trying to be the white guy you
just painted me to be all right fish
tanks
dear barnacle billy
my people are very clever with these
they are i have my listeners are smart
my friend just spent a thousand bucks on
this crazy fish tank and exotic fish to
go with it it's hilarious yeah yeah to
each his own but what's the call here
that's an absolute waste of money it's
not like he has an awesome apartment
that it fits in with the decor on the
other hand that goes to prove he might
have an honest passion for fish tanks i
don't know how to now i don't know how
to feel
please give me your thoughts come back
to seattle
so yeah he sounds like a pothead i like
how this is is bothering him enough that
he's got to write you about it like what
the [ __ ] a thousand dollars yeah you're
living in this [ __ ] you got this
thousand yes oh yeah i was gonna say
uh it's not like he has an awesome
apartment that fits him with the decor
yeah you know but on the other hand it
goes to vice he might have an honest
passion for fish tanks i think looks
like he covered the topic
yeah
he just likes me you know what fish in
the like aquariums are very like calming
to some people so it might be like why
are you making why are you making that
noise because that's that [ __ ] like
somebody said that
and i've never heard a doctor say that
i've heard that repeated
yeah somebody just need a doctor to say
what soothes you or not in order to make
it legitimate they are the ones that
know how to take your blood pressure
you're right so they would actually know
okay how do you know that that didn't
come from the aquarium industry
and when fish fell out of favor at
around 72-73
and people stopped getting aquariums
did you ever hear that that rumor that
tracy morgan had like an octopus or
something like that or oh he has from
what i i've seen uh i've seen video of
it no he has like sharks and [ __ ] yeah
that's kind of cool no he doesn't he
doesn't have to take it and see the see
the little fishies he doesn't have to
take his kids to the aquarium he just
takes him to the living room right
there's no turnstile or nothing
like he could charge money
for his aquarium i think i heard uh
somebody was saying that maybe he was
gonna get a uh
an octopus
yeah i'm just happy that he's still
around and can make that decision i have
to be honest with you i'm looking
forward to when he gets back to the
clubs it seems like buying fish is a
pretty harmless uh habit it can be a
little like what the [ __ ] though if
you've got someone living in this
[ __ ] apartment they're spending a
thousand dollars on fish that's [ __ ]
ridiculous you know when i was a kid my
dad could be worse things my dad used to
we used we used to have piranhas
oh you did yeah we used to call him and
it was always the same name charlie we
had the piranha charlie and you'd throw
the goldfish in
and he would just destroy him oh my god
so much stuff is starting to make sense
and he would eat like you'd put in like
i mean one time
we put like the whole bag in
you've never told me that you owned
piranhas and that you five i didn't know
would like we had a piranha and then we
then my dad had another thing another
tank was called an arowana i swear to
god and it was this eel looking like
fish and that thing used to also eat
fish and it would just go like he'd like
just [ __ ] like lash out i would grab
them
and one time the fish was too big and it
kept hitting it and hitting it and
hitting it and we were all sitting there
laughing
because we thought it was funny then
afterwards we started feeling bad for
the fish so my dad reached in took it
out and brought over the counter and
took a knife and cut its head off and
then threw it back in the tank and
that's my childhood once again so many
things becoming oh stop it
and you know what and someday when the
[ __ ] hits the fan
and the food supply ends
and you can't cut the fish off that head
cut the fish off they cut the head i
think i have dyslexia
do i i mean i can't read i can't even
speak
no it's not that you know what it is cut
the fish off the head it's your add your
brain moves faster than your mouth
and like i know somewhere in there's an
insult you you kind of skimming things
because you're already you want to be
like down here or when you're up here
it's your add i told you
okay get it under control how can you
just [ __ ] diagnose me
i'm right though remember when you died
remember when you took that adult adhd
quiz i made you take that quiz online i
crushed that quiz
i got every answer right crushed it by
being like yes you have adhd we
recommend you like see somebody click on
this link and adam [ __ ] you what are you
doing
and adam levine is sitting there like
hey i also have adhd but that didn't
prevent me from being a huge [ __ ]
rock star why don't you like him
i like him he turned on that guy you
loved him when he first came out i did i
liked him huh
did like maroon 5. i did like it but the
more he started talking the more the
less i liked him but i do like well
maybe if he didn't steal his [ __ ]
music he could just be out in the road
doing that instead of spinning around on
a lazy boy going i want to put you on my
team to sing row row row your boat
all right hot dogs everybody plenty of
money in the maroon 5. and he wants to
be a bigger
star that's why he's on the voice that's
why he's shilling adhd you don't know
you don't know him you're right i don't
know hot dogs bill my girlfriend uh
is grossed out by hot dogs i was
wondering why he didn't go billy
frankfurt there
uh
my girlfriend is grossed out by hot dogs
she says they're made of gross parts of
many animals she's right
i told her i we get it you agree with
the women on this i told her i'm aware
which is which is why i only eat like 12
a year 12 hot dogs a year
hey if you did coke once a month you
wouldn't have a problem that's true
see we're not encouraging people to do
coke
but if you are just do it once a month
just do it once a month which isn't that
much
uh a coupe at a time
a couple i think supposedly a couple at
a time
and only at bbq's that's a lot of bbqs
am i crazy that i think this guy might
be black
why barbecue he put coop you know like
coop deville
basically you're saying that because
this is a cadillac driving
hot dog eating barbecue eating black guy
that's what i'm guessing
so she says she won't kiss me for hours
after eating one so i told her i won't
kiss her for hours after drinking coffee
and let me tell you bill she drinks a
good amount of coffee
how'd i do here um
awful you turned into
the unaccepted skin
now you didn't turn into it you made it
worse
you're like oh you're gonna be a douche
i'll be even a bigger douche and now you
guys aren't going to be kissing yeah
that is the dumbest thing for you guys
to fight about yeah she's going to bang
the guy at the coffee truck
and uh you're going to
[ __ ] a girl in the bleachers i really
love how he eats hot dogs so much that
his girlfriend is like i won't refuse to
kiss you because he eats that many
[ __ ] hot dogs that it's an actual
issue
listen i understand why you eat them and
i also understand that she doesn't want
to kiss the after breath of a pig's
[ __ ]
yeah that's a good point i mean i would
never not kiss you because you ate a hot
dog that's a little extreme for sure oh
and by the way coffee breath coffee
breath coffee i feel like it's probably
worse than hot dog breath
it is right
i think they should put coffee in the
water that they have hot dogs in
coffee dogs
coffee ducks dog coffee uh
either way it's dumb of you guys to be
fighting about this so
yeah as a you guys should be a more
mature couple like myself and nia
all right book suggestion billy
shakespeare uh that's that's another
good one um catching up on old podcasts
and heard you talk about world war ii
books there was that was a year ago read
anything good lately also what magazine
what magazine pique your intro piques
your interest
um he wrote peak
what is he asking about dirty magazines
there
um yeah i was into world war ii books
that was a year ago and i was into that
for like a month and then
my brain goes over here so recently what
did i do
i don't know what i've been reading
about music and uh
i don't [ __ ] know the i i go through
periods of reading and not reading right
now i haven't been reading
you read drum magazines though those are
the magazines and uh that you read a lot
and rolling stone
i read rolling stone yes i do even
though you [ __ ] [ __ ] on that magazine
i just said i believe you said it was
whack
i said that a while ago i actually i i
like reading rolling stone i rather read
about the real life stuff than the
celebrity interviews i just feel like
the celebrity interviews of like not as
not as great as they used to be but i
love reading wow i mean they're real
stuff but they're in the music soldiers
with like ptsd and like any kind of like
internet business thing there was an
article about these two people that met
on vine and started like courting each
other on vine they met in real life and
of course it didn't really work because
you you're in a relationship with
somebody online you don't really know
them and things went south and she
accused him of rape and it was just this
whole [ __ ] terrible situation but i
don't think i can blame it i don't think
you can blame that on vine
i mean
somebody meets you in a bar back in the
day that you don't really know them
either i i know but you at least met
them in real life i blame people who
have relationships with people online
for six months that they've never met in
real life that's a very different
situation than being in this only ten
years you haven't you haven't met the
real me yet man
all right dilemma bill bill and nia if
she's around oh she is definitely around
this oh i'm around
imagine you're
in a perfect relationship i don't have
to imagine it i'm living it oh jesus
nobody believed that
one of your cheats
one of you cheats and it's over
would you rather be the one who cheated
so you
so your image of the other is always
perfect or be the one who got cheated on
so you can have pride in the fact that
you were a good person rough question if
you immerse yourself in the ideas of
both for your own [ __ ] amusement park
terrible questions oh we're not no i'm
not answering that that's stupid
all right let's just we got to do a
dilemma all right
if um
we were in a plane crash okay
and we're
in snowy mountains
i know you don't like the cold no would
you read that rather would you rather
that
i lived and i ate you
are you lived and you ate me now
we're the only ones on this plane yes
that it's come to that
so we can't we can't eat the pilot and
the stewardesses and the other pastors
we were in a very small plane oh i see
um
[Music]
white meat is better for you than dark
meat excuse me dark meat tastes better
um
i could not imagine eating you oh [ __ ]
do that what i'm answering the question
i'm gonna tell you this right now well
the way you've handled closets in here
that's not even a life and death [ __ ]
situation you would totally be like bye
bb
[Laughter]
you know what you do i'd be sitting
there like
still kind of conscious and you do what
tony soprano did to christopher you just
reach over and pinch my nose
oh how that broke my heart when i saw
that scene oh my god
oh that was horrifying and then you'd
stand out there when i did it i [ __ ]
did it i oh that was terrible that and
adriana hurt me the worst on that show
god i [ __ ] love that show so much
remember there was a time where i was
watching like every episode on demand
like every day because i just went back
yeah it was great obsessed with my
sopranos i just loved the food that's
great
that was i loved that period of your tv
watching
yeah that was a great period in your tv
watching you you know it's kind of gone
downhill yeah you have peaks and valleys
and right now yeah you are you are uh
i'm watching a good tv on netflix and
i'm watching the bad tv on actual tv oh
next yeah you yeah well that's gonna
stop when football season starts oh god
by the way that that's that's in less
than a couple weeks college football pro
football
oh boy
vern lundqvist sec football i don't know
what any of those words mean
all right
well it means a lot to me it's exciting
all right everybody that's the podcast
for this week
um
i got i thought i had odd ball dates
this week but uh
i'm definitely doing the jones beach one
but i don't know what's going on with
virginia
ticket sales
are not where they need to be this is
not my call
so it either might happen or it might
not happen
[Music]
i don't know what's going on with
virginia we thought that you guys liked
comedy well thanks a lot everybody
virginia is for lovers not for comedians
that's right not for psycho comics
um all right that's it
[Music]
um that's a podcast everybody go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week
thank you for listening
bye bye
you